[Music]
charlotte
that voice always surprises me charlotte
if you can go next please
and i can go next uh my name is
charlotte weiss i
am also an mba 2 here at gsb
and i'm originally from new york and
in addition to found co-founding nbsa
my favorite experience at the gsb was my
global studies trip
to brazil last year awesome
so we'll definitely touch into that as
well but i was hoping greg
if we could start with you actually
could you tell us a little bit about the
knack
sure uh so native american cultural
center
or more commonly known as nak is one of
the
four ethnic community centers on campus
so there's the asian american activity
center
black services center uh black service
community center
uh el centro chicano and then ourselves
uh
so our goal at the knack is kind of
three things
to um help build native community
we have roughly 450 native students
across campus
um to share our native culture
and then to create campus and
community and alumni connections so
as i mentioned before uh the knack is
located um
just across from the bookstore you stand
on the steps of the bookstore look
across the way we're on the left-hand
side
so we are the physical and now virtual
home for
for indigenous students and indigenous
we cast that net
widely american indian alaska native
native hawaiian
first nations um folks from
maori from new zealand indigenous
pacific islanders
um a number of folks from south of that
line drawn across the bottom of the
united states
um so anyone
who has indigenous heritage is welcome
and also people who are interested in
native
issues so let's see some of the programs
we do
we start off with the grad welcome
barbecue we fire up the charcoal and
grill some steaks and salmon
it's a good start to the school year uh
this year no
we have monthly community dinners um
and basically just kind of social events
to get people together
we host quarterly uh scholarly or
academic speakers
uh often visiting professors at stanford
um
the two big events that we helped do
are polynesian cultural fest kind of aka
luau and that's a saturday afternoon
generally in april and then our biggest
most well-known event is the stanford
university pow-wow and that keeping our
fingers crossed
we'll have it in person this year which
would be our 50th anniversary
and that's the largest student-run
powwow in the country
um there is a student native student
group
graduate student called snags and that's
kind of a cute little
term there so in addition to
kind of social events they do a lot of
kind of outdoor
hike to the dish get together and have
s'mores up at lake logg
they went to the native american film
festival and also do oh they did a ski
trip last year up to tahoe
so we have lots of opportunities to
get together and be involved yeah this
is a
very special year um 50th for
a celebration for a couple of different
organizations so powwows won
one of the events and then also saio i
believe
also their 50th the stanford american
indian organization
was founded 50 years ago yes amazing and
so
um just so excited that you're able to
join us if you do need to hop off i
understand
um if anything i'm also happy to direct
folks to the neck
it's a wonderful resource and for those
on the call i just want you to know
i've been at stanford for a while and
one of the people i
immediately associate when i think of
the word community
is greg he is one of the backbones and
cornerstones
of like the entire um stanford community
and
he is a wonderful gift to have on campus
so
greg i just want to provide that
acknowledgement to you as well thank you
for everything you do for us in our
community
thank you for those kind words um
speaking of the knack i think charlotte
and renee might actually have
a story for us um cold calling them on
that if
y'all would be so willing to share yeah
i'm happy to share
because it's partly why we founded the
nbsa
at the gsb um so charlotte and i
actually met at one of the knack events
it was the welcome barbecue that greg
so graciously hosts for us and it was
one of those moments where i was like
hey i'm
i'm a gsv student and charlotte was like
wait you're a gsp student i'm a gsb
student like how are we just meeting for
the first time how do we not know we
both have this
shared native experience and it just led
to so many conversations and ultimately
the founding of nbsa
and we hope that it can also be a
resource for anyone on this call
um who ends up at the gsb to be a part
of the native community at stanford
yeah and just to chime in
um we we both came to the event
alone not knowing anybody and
that's because that was something we we
both felt comfortable doing at a place
like the knack and just
at stanford everyone is so welcoming
that it was something that i i said okay
this is something that's important to me
i'm gonna go to it
on my own and and running into renee
there was was such a delight
nice um so as you
like the idea of like hey let's come
together how did you go about starting
um
nbsa i can take that question
um i i came about starting nbsa well
before i even got to stanford honestly
when i was looking at mba programs i
pretty quickly noticed that
not not one business school that was in
my
on my list of places i wanted to apply
had
a formal native business students
association um
and so it was kind of in the back of my
mind wherever i ended up
wanted it to be stanford because of its
really strong native presence already
but wherever i ended up it was something
that was important um
for for me to to make a reality
wherever um i went to business school
and so
when renee and i met it was immediately
it was great okay we've got we've got
manpower now we can we can work together
to to bring this to life and
um we we reached out to you well we kind
of we spoke about this was something
that we wanted to do and
um and got a lot of support from
the administration as we kind of went
through the steps
of taking a new idea
into a new club proposal through gsb
student government and then stanford
student government more broadly and
by winter quarter of last year we were
official
that is such that's one of my favorite
like
serendipitous beginnings for um one of
our for our community
um so as we like backtrack a little bit
can you tell me a little
like why why business school to begin
with given
so many different options out there and
i know some of the folks
who are tuning in today um might be
considering a couple of different
pathways
so maybe for renae and charlotte what
brought you here and then greg
for folks who are thinking about
graduate school
generally any tips thoughts given that
you have a broad vision of the many
different paths
folks have taken especially here at
stanford
yeah i'm happy to start on why business
school
so before the gsb i was working in
finance and specifically private equity
so i came from a
pretty traditional business background
um for me personally i didn't
feel like the finance realm was a
personally good fit for me and i really
wanted to transition and make a career
pivot
into a career with a lot more meaning
for me that was looking into the
healthcare industry so i was looking at
a master in public health and also an
mba
i decided to pursue an mba specifically
because i
felt on the business side of health that
i could
create more impact at scale versus a
master in public health where i may be
able to only help one or two patients
or focus solely on the administrative
side so i'm happy to say i was able to
make the career pivot and was able to
intern at a healthcare company this
summer davida
and i'm looking forward to returning
this fall
and then for me i wanted to go to
business school
because i had a i came from consulting
which is very much a traditional
background but then found myself
in a role that i really loved um but
working in
an hr function at a large corporation
and realized that the upward trajectory
in that role
was something that was interesting to me
but um i realized it kind of siloed my
career
um a bit a bit earlier than i would have
than i would have
ultimately liked and also had always
kind of been fascinated by and really
enticed by the
opportunity to um to think
critically and really spend time
focusing on developing myself and my own
strengths as a leader
and so business school really presented
an opportunity from a career perspective
to
kind of re-expand my aperture of what uh
what was what is available
in terms of my my existing skill set and
then build on the things that
i had noticed were blind spots in my
career
at the time and really strengthen what
what i'm hoping will be a long career as
a business leader
and then greg any vision for like how
you've seen like
graduate studies prepare and think about
the path that they choose knowing that
business school is just one of many
potentials ah
um graduate school is different than
undergrad
in undergrad you come in and you can do
anything and everything
graduate school is much more focused so
when you apply to graduate school you
need to have a better idea of what you
want to do
there are lots of good schools um so
do your research um don't just buy the
brand name
each school has its own personality and
you know it may be a top school but it
doesn't fit right with you
so you know do your homework that way
and
you know just go for it nice
speaking of the just go for it as you
were thinking about
grad school what are some of the things
that you did to prepare renee and
charlotte
so i think that this is is commonly
heard
and recommended especially in preparing
for business school but i did a lot of
reflection
and a lot of it like self introspection
and really thinking about what it was
that i wanted out of an mba program
and what i felt was kind of missing from
my current state and needed an mba to to
get to that desired future state so i
really encourage
really encourage everyone to to to do
more than just
think about thinking about yourself um
and hearing that advice but really
internalize it especially
you know over the holidays is a really
it was a really good opportunity to
to do that and that was i applied round
two so it really kind of
added i think extra depth to to my
essays and to my admissions package
overall
um and i think that that's
that was the that was the biggest piece
beyond that a lot of the
the tactical steps and i'm sure renee
can can speak to some of those so
i'll let you go yeah i would echo what
charlie said about really reflecting on
what you want and
even more specifically for me it was
like why now why
why a grad degree now and also
thinking about like why this where what
this degree was going to take me
and something that i did to prepare that
i found really helpful was actually
reaching out to a lot of alumni
across a variety of schools across a
variety of master's programs
just to answer like what career
trajectory did they take what did they
take away
from their program and why was it so
impactful
so i think if you have an opportunity to
connect i know charlotte and i are very
happy to connect
um but if you want to talk more i think
just having those conversations and
reflecting on
why now um is the first step
yeah so i'm going to use that to plug
our q and a box
because right now would actually be a
prime time to connect with all three
of our panelists so definitely start
popping questions into there
and we can have that be the guide for
our conversation
charlotte i think we actually interacted
pretty early on like cross path can you
tell me a little bit about
actually that time yes absolutely
so um so will i
will and i met at um at events for
mlt which is management leadership for
tomorrow
and that is a pre-mba program for
underrepresented minorities and it was
something that
really helped me prepare my applications
and just gave
extra extra rigor and a set of
eyes on for people who have been through
this process
before um because it's it's it's scary
applying to mba programs when you kind
of feel like you're going in blind um
but i i've jokingly i've shared this
with will but i truly believed it at the
time i was
very intimidated by will at these events
um because any time i was any time there
was a
kind of a breakfast or any sort of
social hour where you can talk to all
these different business school
reps will was surrounded by students and
i was just like oh man
stanford gosh i will must be very scary
he was like there's there's like he's
been getting mobbed and so i always was
kind of like shy away but
clearly as everyone could see on the
panel will is about
the nicest most warm-hearted person
i i think i've ever met and so um
so that was that was that was will in my
history we go way back
i laugh because now she that she knows
me i'm like just
a smiling like bald bobble head that's
here to affirm and support you
regardless of what you do like um
we really do care about each other here
at stanford um
so charlotte a couple more things about
mlt just for the folks
out there um like i'm all about sharing
resources can you tell me about what's a
couple of the things that mlt does to
help you prepare
for sure um so mlt
again i i applied a few years ago when
when we weren't in a
pandemic so we had a couple of um of
conferences which i'm sure are now
virtual
um but those were to really um get to
know some of the
admissions officers and get a lot of
those questions that
renee and that renee alluded to um
seeking answers from alumni
um doing that and getting the admissions
perspective was really
really instrumental and valuable um
and then there was also essay review
and resume reviews so really helping
prepare and package your application
in a really strong way especially um
for the programs that we were most
interested in
there was gmat help and really just
every
every step of the way there was there
was support from
our our kind of fellow who was
our coach we called them um but really
what i enjoyed and took away most from
the program was the cohort and the
experience of being a part of the mlt
community
it was something that i knew i would
enjoy just as a generally social person
but
um really being able to lean on others
going through
the same admissions process as i was and
working on our applications we were able
to read each other's essays
my good friend gave me a mock interview
when i was preparing
and really being able to have that being
able to commiserate together over
this this shared experience um because
like greg said you know
not every when you're going to business
school it's a lot more focused and not
everyone around you is applying like
they were during undergrad
and so mlt really provided a special
home for me in that respect nice thanks
so for those on the call mlt we just
talked about there's another
there's a few other organizations out
there that
many of our peer schools also work with
so one that
while stanford is not a partner school
might be of interest to you is
the consortium and so through there they
have a shared application that you can
apply to multiple schools and there's
also a consortium fellowship
uh there's also also the forte
foundation which works um
advent with the advancement of women in
business and they also have men as
allies
um so and there's also jumpstart it's
another program that was started by john
burt
uh that also works with helping with the
advancement of underserved minorities in
business education
so we can go ahead and pop some of those
resources into the chat box but i just
want to make sure folks know
there are resources out there um that
you know you can tap into
and so i'm going to shift over to the q
a box so i'm actually going to start
with you greg
i'm going to adapt the question um for
you because you have some very special
insight here
so this question is an adaptation from
chip
so what keeps you at stanford what
are what are the things that you know
have you here as opposed to any other
school
or um like setting that you could be in
oh my gosh how long do we have
uh the the background behind charlotte
is one of the reasons it's an incredibly
beautiful place
uh act you can tell i'm sitting outside
and it's about
right about 60 degrees a little bit of
sun so you know it's a gorgeous
california day
and as will was saying community at
stanford
i was at a graduate diversity admit
weekend
and the president was there and he was
introducing himself not as
the president of stanford university but
by his first name
and talking to the to the admits i'm
going like holy smokes
um i remember when i was an undergrad
there
the professors were all very accessible
and you know there are folks at the biz
school who
are very generous in sharing about their
experience renee and charlotte
there are other alums over the years if
you're interested
it's like oh this was my my experience
as an any person there
and then of course there's will and
actually a fair number of people who
were just
or like will wonderful people to work
with so um
i think it's a great place and holy
smokes i've been there quite a long time
now
since 2000. i love that you're saying
like
it's a nice 60 degrees you have a little
bit of extra insulation
i i have the covered fur it's 35 weeks
long oh
actually pretty impressive i've gotta
say
that it is it is beautiful weather here
but it does
make us pretty wimpy as far as like
we were like oh it's it's sub 60 like i
gotta be inside
where we're making sure that there's
them wearing like heavy jacket and i'm
from new york and so
i've really uh really grown soft
in this beautiful california weather
yeah um so
that actually might be a factor to the
the version of the question i'm gonna
ask you renee and charlotte like
considering that you probably were
choosing among different schools or even
as you're thinking about schools to
apply to
what were some of the things about
stanford that really spoke to you
yeah uh i would say first and foremost
stanford has just always been
a dream school for me it's just an
amazing academic institution the level
of rigor
i think it's such a strong brand and
network i mean all of those things aside
like
stanford is incredible reputation and
like
continues to exceed my expectations of
it every day
i would say on top of that what makes
stanford special for me
is just the emphasis on personal
development
i've never had a program that emphasizes
personal reflection and personal growth
like stanford and specifically the gsb
does
and i think for me it's just really i've
learned so much about myself
in this like few months and then i would
say the second piece is just
continuing to build those relationships
stanford really
is a community um and the knack is just
one of those pieces of the community
and everyone here has always supported
one another and i'm just like
continually surprised and excited by
how we show up for one another both
academically
and professionally
and for me um echoing a lot of what
renee
said i because i loved my career
i was i was approaching the nba
process looking for you know was this
going to be
a program worthy of my time of the money
of the opportunity cost of two years of
salary
and so i was looking at programs with
rigor
like stanford's and similar to them
also i'm sorry if you could hear any
background noise at all
there's a leaf blower in
my house's backyard that i did not
expect to be here right now
um but i can speak loudly if if you are
um but for me it was really um in
addition to
the personal introspection something
that i really loved about stanford
is the the breadth
of passions and interests as far as
a careers perspective of what people
choose
um i won't name names but i went to a
at admissions week admitted students
weekend at another school i was
considering
and they had panels on all these
different careers
and one of the person's leading one of
the people like asked to send us off to
the panel
said ah but you're all going to go into
banking and consulting anyway
and i was like oh no because i came from
consulting and i'm not going into
banking that's for sure and so
just that just even that joke it kind it
really um
i really took it to heart and at
stanford i think that you know there are
over 400 classmates and
over 400 career paths that people are
gonna go down and that was something
that
um didn't even stand out to me as
such a defining factor of what i wanted
from my mba program until
until i was admitted and and recognized
just
just how special and valuable that is
so there's another really good question
here that i'm going to adapt
to again to our different panels knowing
that we have some really different
perspectives here that are going to be
helpful so this question
is from cheyenne um on the indigenous
experience so for renee and charlotte
for you how
um kind of at that first person level
and then greg really
um kind of knowing that you are so much
of a mentor and role model
and how have you seen this kind of
emerge for students
so the question is how has being
indigenous impacted your mba experience
um what's the native community like at
stanford and so for greg like
how have you seen students identities um
kind of
impact or influence the way they move
through the university maybe that might
be a good way to approach it from from
your direction
so any one of you can go ahead and start
students should start
yeah i can start um i think
first and foremost my mom grew up on the
navajo reservation
um so she was the first person in her
family to leave the reservation to go to
college
um and just having that as an experience
my mom has just really valued education
for me and really strive for me to push
myself
academically i would say even more so
just spending time on the reservation
growing up defines so many of my
personal values
and a lot of what we look at as a leader
is how to bring those
values authentically to your leadership
style
and more specifically for me at the gsb
how do i bring that into a role as a
business leader both as like
a woman and an indigenous community
member
and so i think for me it's impacted both
how i
relate to my peers at the gsb and
sharing that different perspective there
are so few
native students at the gsb and i feel
really empowered
to bring that new perspective to the
community and then more personally
how do i reflect on my own personal
values and what does that mean for me as
a business leader going forward
and can i support and champion other
native business students as they
go through the same career path
yeah i love what renee said about
especially around
representation i too i've been
reflect really honored to be able to
take my my identity and really think
about how
i can apply who i am and how i show up
as a native woman in the working world i
um i grew up across the country from
my reservation and um my family has
lived
off of our reservation for four
generations now
so my connection um my connection to my
my native roots is very much through my
my family and the oral traditions we
share um
and that is something that it's really
important for me to to keep that legacy
and those oral traditions alive
even um even outside of
academic experiences which has been
really beyond
my own my own tribe and my own family
the only
opportunity that i've had to really
um really represent what it means to be
indigenous what it means to be native
and so
doing that in the context of the gsb has
been a really
perfect segue into how am i going to
take
this identity of mine and let it shine
when i return
to the working world
right um yes
uh in indigenous people have a i guess
a unique world view and um
a value of community and tribe and
helping people together which is
you know probably fairly unique in in
america
at stanford like i mentioned before we
have over 450 native students
some folks are you know full blood
lakota they speak their language
uh myself i was born and raised in the
suburbs of northern california
my tribal heritage is delaware western
oklahoma so california's a long ways
from oklahoma
and the only people i knew were aunts
and uncles and cousins
so you know we all have our own
trajectory and path of
finding that out and expressing it
the community at stanford is very open
to
you know wherever you are from where you
started you know please come
join learn more and share
yeah kind of on that similar level greg
what have been some of the
kind of topics of conversation that have
been happening at the knack recently
um probably one of the biggest topics
is uh covet especially on the navajo
reservation
they're an incredibly rural
reservation in arizona new mexico and
they had more cases per capita
than new york city and they are
completely and totally
underserved by doctors nurses and
hospitals and so that's a huge
problem and then
getting the native vote out i mean in
many areas of the country
um the county officials aren't quite so
enthused about native people voting and
they're
they put place lots of obstacles there
um
so the the election in covet i think
have been the two biggest things
recently i think that's
both things that have been like
prescient on all our minds but
with like definite added nuance for the
community
um kind of while we're on the topic of
kovid
um kind of a not so smooth segway
but for renee and charlotte um can you
tell us a little bit about how
you've navigated or like what the
experience was like because
you've had both a quote unquote
traditional
part of your start to your business
school career and now you're kind of in
this
unprecedented time of business school
education can you talk a little bit
about
kind of your observations on the
experience
yeah i'm happy to start um
i think business school is very unique
and that it has a huge emphasis on
your social experience and and a lot of
people go to business school
to you know expand their career
opportunities by
you know creating a large network of
friends
at business school and also interacting
to practice those leadership skills um
that we emphasize so much here and so i
think when we
kind of turned to this covet era and
these unprecedented
times it was really hard particularly on
business students just because that
social component is
so important
oh i think you got there you go
i have to take over
sorry or no renee you look like you
oh okay can you guys hear me now okay
sorry my favorite freaked out
um i will say though so once covet hit
and we hit these unprecedented times
because we just had a foundation
of community collaboration at the gsb
everyone rallied um there was no
hesitation to try and continue those
connections
regardless of what format that looked
like now so i'm just so proud to be part
of this community
where we may not have traditional social
interactions we still have such a
commitment to each other and those
connections
to support one another and i think on
top of that the administration
and professors and clubs and spaces
where we call home like the knack
have done an incredible job of just
being there and supporting us
in any way they can
yeah and renee and i are also both
arbuckle leadership fellows so we while
we're not mba ones we can
kind of speak to the nba one experience
a bit
um i think it's been most interesting
for
for us as nba 2s because we had
two quarters where the world looked
pretty ordinary
and now what's looking like the latter
half of our experience
um is going to be in this new normal
uh we really have this like 50 50 split
and we felt extremely lucky that we
had the two quarters that we could get
to know each other
and so that we you know had connection
and community
before everything went online and
felt frankly really nervous for the
incoming mba ones of how they were going
to be able
to to foster that and to have a good
experience when their classes were
online and a lot of the things that we
cherished like i mentioned my global
studies trip obviously not happening
anymore um
but you know as soon as they arrived it
was kind of
i kind of joked it was like why were
any of us ever worrying about stanford
gsb students
not finding a solution to these sort of
problems and my goodness like the amount
of
slack channels and just virtual
gatherings that have been happening and
they had socially distanced picnics and
i
i mean you name it like they they
thought of
many many different ways to to foster
that community and get to know each
other
on a really deep level that um that it's
been it's been really impressive and the
the positivity amongst the nba ones just
coming into school
knowing that it wasn't gonna look the
way that
um traditional mba programs begin
but seeing them really rise to the
occasion has been
really inspiring and and really kind of
affirming that that you can
you can create community um in any
circumstance
yeah um kind of semi-related renee can
you tell me a little bit about like the
arbuckle fellows program like what is it
how how is this interaction with the nba
ones happening
yeah i'm really happy to speak about
this um charlie and i are actually in
the same
fellow fellows group which is really
exciting
um but the arbelco fellows program is a
leadership program
that the gsb has for second year
mba students so you apply your first
year
and once you get into the program you're
able to
take what is called interpersonal
dynamics which is known as one of the
hallmark classes of the gsb
otherwise referred to as touchy-feely
and you work on
how you impact others in everyday
conversations
and then from there during your second
year you take on
what we call a little squad of mba ones
and you
teach them through a leadership course
called leadership laboratories
where they run role plays pretending to
be executives
and finding out their strengths and
weaknesses as a leader and through the
fellows program it's our job to provide
feedback
and support and help them find their own
leadership voice through this journey
and on top of that you have some
personal leadership coaches
um and you just create a huge skill set
of you know how do you create a culture
within
a team how do you lead a team how do you
lead a team to find their own leadership
style
and then also coaching and supporting
other mba ones through this experience
and bringing your own authentic self is
it's just been
an a tremendous experience for me i've
learned so much about myself
and i hope to continue to grow as a
leader a mentor
a coach um and a person okay so
no problem so we're gonna do a little
bit of a role play here
and it this is actually inspired by one
of the questions and knowing that
there's no right or wrong answers
there's someone here who would like to
know what advice would you share with
someone
let's say they're applying to something
maybe it's business school maybe it's a
job
but they might be intimidated about
rejection
how would you coach them or what would
you encourage them to think about
to help them through the situation
love this role play um
look that's it's super real and we
we all certainly experienced it um
impostor syndrome
is um pervasive even here at the gsb
and i would say
staying true to yourself is is not only
the
easiest way to to present in an
application in a job interview because
you're not trying to put on a face or
use that extra energy to be something
you're not
um but that authenticity um pays
like kind of pays back in dividends it's
really
special to meet someone or to to
sit across an interview with someone who
is pretty unapologetically themselves
and i think that that self-awareness to
really
offer you know what you know to be your
strengths and then even more importantly
what you
recognize as your blind spots or your
weaknesses and
treat those as learning opportunities of
where you're looking to improve
um is really what i would say
allows for that rejection to to
feel to be less of a of a blow because
you know that you you gave it your all
being
being true to yourself trying to fit a
sort of mold
in the in the attempt to get in
somewhere
doesn't really make that acceptance in
my view feel
um feel as good
yeah and i can also speak to that i
would i would say
i would hope to explore those feelings
of
why why how rejection has
um influenced you in the past and then
thinking about
you know every leader every person faces
rejection
and failure throughout their career but
i would hope to reframe that in your
mind as just
doing your best is all you can do and
those
sometimes those rejection or failures
are out of your control
and once you know you've done your best
can you look at those
as learning opportunities like charlotte
said but also just more data points of
how you can keep improving
and hopefully next time turn it around
and i hope that's helpful
your mba ones and your squads are so
lucky to have you if you have any extra
coaching spots like i
i'd sign up
um so this might be a question um that
might have the answer might have changed
because of kovid or
maybe because um you're still developing
kind of goals as a an organization
so can you tell talk a little bit about
like um how do you
see the potential for um like
cross-collaboration across the school as
kind of nbsa
any thoughts on kind of potential
integration with undergrads
or um kind of by extension what what are
some of the
initiatives or things that you hope nbsa
is going to be able to
um kind of approach in the coming year
yeah um so the mbsa i think was unique
because we were
the last actually grad program to add a
native
uh a native club um so all the other
grad programs
including the undergrad have really
strong native
club communities so what we're trying to
do is actually work with those other
grad
programs to see what has worked for them
um how can we generate community within
the business school
so we've been leaning on them a lot um
to help guide us
get this club off the ground and we hope
in the future that we could create
um like greg mentioned snags as more of
a collective grad unit for all native
um grad students at stanford and
hopefully we can have some events
together and just
continue to enjoy the powwows we weren't
able to participate last year but we
hope we can
participate this year um even with snags
last year
we were able to just go to dinner and
just have fun together and i think just
spending time
with that community was really special
and also just having friends outside of
your grad program to add perspective
and other native perspectives into your
community as well
yeah i'll add to that is that sometimes
the gsb very much can feel
like we're a bubble um there's so much
going on and so much to do within our
own community that
it takes some very concerted effort to
um to expand outside of the business
school
and knack has really provided both renee
and myself with
with that um with that perspective and
that community that's not just at the
gsb
and so continuing to continuing to
liaise with them and then kind of use
use them to help build up what but we're
hoping to be a strong
presence at the gsb that knapp has in
broader stanford community is definitely
um
of importance to the two of us and greg
there's questions
for you um how have you seen like some
of the collaboration among the different
um
organizations on campus like how have
things evolved over time
um very much like renee said
the organizations are working together
closer and closer um
there are you know only about 100 native
grad students
which compared to many schools that's a
whole lot but it's still only 100.
and so we really do need to be together
work together collaborate and
charlotte said you know biscuits really
intense and
you know you're in your own little
business school world and it's sometimes
hard to break out of that
but doing that um you know adds to your
friend network your
social network your professional network
and
a different perspective i mean it's so
important to
like kind of just step away and
relax a little bit out of whatever
program you're in
and will you asked about undergrads the
the native undergrads are really hungry
to learn about graduate school you know
how did you choose it
why did you decide this you know mba
instead of law school
and so they they love to hear from
native grad students so
possible idea for future events kind of
planting the scenes
you know i was trying to build
connections wherever we can
um so i'm actually curious a little bit
more about
um you both mentioned a lot about
introspection
um as part of the business school
journey which i think
when people think business school
introspection is not necessarily
the first thing they think of um
so have either of you so you've taken
interpersonal dynamics can you walk us
through like
what kind of what did you do in those
classes and like
did you have any aha moments or
observations about your
own leadership development
absolutely um and it's true i think that
um
that when you think about an mba program
you're thinking about accounting and
finance which is very much part of the
gsb
um but just like any other program
but um but as soon as you really start
learning about
mbas it's just as much about
the uh the new the numbers and that like
quantitative rigor as it is about
becoming a leader and that and becoming
a leader i think one of the most
important qualities that i that i see
and and leaders i admire and respect is
um is their ability to be self-aware and
to have a growth mindset towards um
their own development opportunities even
at the helm of a large organization
um so self self reflection and that
introspective piece really is
um is integral to to applying and being
a part of an mba program
but to answer your your more specific
question um
that those those aha moments they really
they
began day one because um
leadership labs the the class that renee
spoke to um the both of us now leading
in our mba two-year
that is that is something that you take
fall quarter and
you immediately learn about um
the action impact model for delivering
feedback as an example
and showing that you know instead of
feeling frustrated and saying
you did this or like you you were really
rude to me
um just being able to reframe feedback
and saying you know when you spoke in
this way
i felt disrespected and and that just
slight switch in in the way you use
language um
was a pretty big aha moment for me week
one
um and if i were to
tell you about all of the aha moments
that i've had in the past
year and a half or so it'd be a time for
an entirely
separate panel um but really just
through
through lead labs through interpersonal
dynamics now being a fellow
um it's been amazing just seeing a lot
of things kind of
come together in ways that i never would
have expected
and really um really helped me hone in
on kind of
what what makes me me
yeah and i think building off what
charlie was saying
i think one question i've really
reflected on
or spent a lot of my introspection on is
just why would someone
follow me like what do i bring to the
table
that makes it um unique or how do i
generate buy-in and build trust
and so i think through like
interpersonal dynamics you explore a lot
of these
topics of how do you think about
building trust but then how do you
integrate that with firing someone
how do you think about being your most
authentic self
but being able to adapt to any business
environment
or personal environment and so thinking
through those questions of
who am i what do i bring that's unique
and why would i
why would i invite team members to
follow me
i think it just takes a personal
responsibility and an empathetic leader
to understand what every person is going
through and and what it really truly
means
to ask someone to follow you and that
responsibility you take on as a leader
so
thinking through those questions at the
gsb um beyond
all of the other like leadership
opportunities here has been something
that has been
really beneficial for me it's
interesting it's like
um come urban mba and do some
existential pondering
oh so we are getting close to the top of
the hour this time actually really
flew but um for our last question
i'm gonna claim this one for myself
for our students to a younger you
whether it was in the application
process
or maybe it was last year that first
year as you were starting
what advice would you give yourself and
for greg
what advice would you give to folks who
are thinking about
graduate programs just kind of writ
large
so i'll give you a moment to um think on
that and then whenever someone's ready
go ahead and pop on
i'll start um and also
renee is referring me to me as charlie
because charlie is my nickname and
that's what she calls me i
keep meaning to to call that out um but
yes just in case that was confusing to
anybody
um but anyways uh advice that i would
give
my younger self i think is still advice
that applies
today um but it's to
trust that things will work out
the way that they ought to um
i i make up her i'm intentionally don't
use the word
should because i think that like should
can be a really
um scary path to go down of
what like should versus should not but
um
you know there were there were times in
college and jobs that i didn't get and
career moments in my career that i
really thought um
i really thought we're gonna we're gonna
be damning or just were
were keeping me up at night um
got passed over for promotions a lot of
just a lot of things where where there
was maybe signs of
of darkness or strife that um
that looking back on now i know
that they were they all happened for a
reason which is super
cheesy to say and to hear myself say out
loud to but
um but everything
led me here one way or another um and
i'm really
i'm really happy to be here and i think
that
um it's advice that i need to continue
to continue to take even
um even now as we look ahead
and think about have a lot of choice in
front of us
as far as you know where um where to end
up next year
and how to spend our remaining two
quarters
and i think that it's it's a lesson that
that will be kind of taught and
re-taught time and time again
yeah i think that's amazing advice um
trusting the process and having the
faith that it'll work out
i think if i could go back and tell
myself
something it would just be to believe in
myself
a bit more um which is a beyond that
like trust the process
piece i was so hesitant to apply to
business school at first and i thought
stanford was just such a reach for me i
was like no way
and um i think if i would just go back
and just say believe in myself
and going through that application
process i know it's just so taxing
um and it can take a long time but i
wish i
just was my i know everyone can be their
biggest critic but i wish i was
my biggest fan too um and going through
that process and remembering like
you do enough you are enough um you
deserve
and well everything will work out um so
i think i would
uh tell myself that and give myself some
confidence
um to keep going and pursue whatever
dream i have
to add to all that excellent advice um
develop a strong why on what on
why you want to go to bus school or any
graduate program
um and that's the reflection and where
you're going to go with it what are you
going to do with it
do research i mean this is an investment
of two years of time and a
fair amount of tuition so you wouldn't
just jump into an investment like
hey that sounds great let me do that so
you know
do do research and and find the right
fit um
as renee said i think reach um
you know gosh way back in the day when i
applied to stanford's and undergrads
like oh there's no
and it's like whoa oh my gosh there we
are
and if you don't apply you absolutely
won't get in
um there's a great book uh john maxwell
sometimes you win sometimes you learn
and so if if you if you need to learn
uh you know learn and try to get up and
try it again
great thank you so much
to everybody who joined us today as
in our audience thank you so much to our
panelists for joining us
sharing time and sharing space and also
thank you for allowing me to be part of
the community
you just bring so much joy to like
my work and my week and i hope we're
able to share some of that joy with
everybody out here today